Islam is often presented as a very
simple religion it's just submission to
Allah the god of Islam but if you dig a
Little Deeper you find out in the Quran
Surah 4 verse 65 that submission to
Allah requires complete obedience to all
of Muhammad's teachings you heard that
correctly in Islam you can only submit
to God by fully submitting to a man and
that's where Islam gets a lot more
complicated because Muhammad's teachings
are spread across thousands of stories
in these massive multi-volume
collections of hadiths most Christians
and most Muslims don't have the time or
the desire to go through these books and
figure out what Islam teaches so Muslims
tend to listen to what their sheikhs and
imams tell them about Islam and
Christians sadly tend to not learn
anything about Islam and that's a huge
problem there are more than 1.6 billion
Muslims in the world and Islam places a
strong emphasis on preaching and winning
converts when your Muslim friends tell
you about how amazing the Quran is or
when your children go off to college and
hear about how wonderful Muhammad was
not only from their Muslim friends but
also from their professors it would be
extremely helpful to know some relevant
information about Islam in fact since
Christians and Muslims are interacting
more than ever before thanks in large
part to the internet I think it's safe
to say that Christians in general all of
us need to learn something about Islam
rather than throw a ton of information
at you all at once I'm going to give you
three simple verses from the Quran now I
would love to see Christians around the
world learn 10 or 15 of the most
important Quran verses but if I were to
narrow down the list to just three
absolutely essential verses three verses
that will help you over and over and
over again in your discussions with
Muslims these would be the three
first Surah 4 verse 157 surahs are
basically chapters so chapter 4 verse
157 of the Quran this verse gives the
Islamic view of Jesus crucifixion let's
read it in the Yusuf Ali translation
which is the most popular English
translation
that they said in boast they here are a
group of Jews they said in boast we
killed Christ Jesus the son of Mary the
messenger of Allah but they killed him
not nor crucified him only a likeness of
that was shown to them and those who
differ therein are full of doubts with
no certain knowledge but only conjecture
to follow for of a surety they killed
him not
notice that Jesus wasn't killed
according to the Quran he wasn't even
crucified Islam denies that Jesus
crucifixion ever took place
at least that's the dominant
interpretation there have been Muslim
Scholars who interpret this passage
differently for instance certain Muslim
Scholars have suggested that what Allah
is really saying here is that if you
think you've Killed Someone Like Jesus
if you think you won a victory over
Jesus by executing him you're mistaken
because Jesus is still alive and
everything is happening exactly as Allah
planned but that's a minority view
historically the vast majority of
Muslims and Muslim Scholars have
understood this passage as a complete
denial of Jesus crucifixion
now if Jesus was never crucified what
happened
the standard Islamic narrative is that
Allah miraculously disguised someone
else to make him look like Jesus and it
was this other person who was crucified
not Jesus the reason you believe that
Jesus died according to Islam is that
Allah did an excellent job tricking
everyone
so Islam denies the crucifixion by
portraying Allah as a Divine Trickster
fun topic for discussion second Surah 5
verse 47 Muslims often claim that the
Bible has been corrupted but there are
plenty of verses in the Quran which show
that if the Bible has been corrupted
Allah certainly doesn't know anything
about it Surah 5 verse 47 is one of
these verses in Surah 5 verse 47 Allah
commands Christians to judge by the
gospel Allah says
let the people of the Gospel judge by
what Allah hath revealed therein if any
do fail to judge by what Allah hath
revealed they are those who Rebel
Allah commands Christians to judge not
by the Koran but by the gospel and he
says that we're Rebels if we don't
clearly we can only judge by the gospel
if we actually have the gospel so the
Quran assumes that Christians still have
reliable scriptures
of course if we obey Allah and we judge
by the gospel we have to conclude that
Islam is false because we've already
seen that Islam contradicts the gospel
the gospel says that Jesus died on the
cross the Quran Surah 4 verse 157 says
that Jesus didn't die on the cross which
one should we listen to
well the Quran orders us to judge by the
gospel therefore if we listen to the
Quran we have to reject the Quran
see why I gave you these two verses
third Surah 9 verse 29 if you've never
understood why Christians and other
religious minorities are so horribly
mistreated in places like Iraq and Egypt
and Pakistan the primary reason for the
oppression is found in the Quran
Allah commands his followers once their
Community is strong enough to violently
subjugate Christians and Jews Allah says
in 929
fight those who believe not in Allah nor
the last day notice it says fight those
who do not believe and not fight in
self-defense this is a command to fight
People based on their beliefs
fight those who believe not in Allah nor
the last day nor hold that forbidden
which hath been forbidden by Allah and
his messenger nor acknowledge the
religion of truth from among the people
of the book the people of the book are
Jews and Christians until they pay the
jizya with willing submission and feel
themselves subdued
jizya is tribute money that you pay to
people who are superior to you in order
to publicly acknowledge your inferior
status
Allah commands his followers to fight
Jews and Christians until we pay this
tribute money to them and feel ourselves
subdued Surah 9 verse 29 requires
Christians to accept our status as
second-class citizens who don't have the
same rights as our Muslim superiors this
command has probably led to more
oppression than any other command in
history
interestingly the very next verse of the
Quran gives the reason for violently
subjugating Christians we have to be
violently oppressed because we say that
Jesus is the son of God
but why do Christians call Jesus the son
of God
because that's what the gospel says
about him
so should we reject the gospel
what does the Quran command us to judge
by again
the gospel
see how I picked three passages that
deal with topics that are all extremely
important to Christians and yet the
three passages can be connected in ways
that highlight problems for the divine
origin of the Quran
learn these three verses and I guarantee
that opportunities to use them will
suddenly arise now if you'd like to dig
a Little Deeper to become even more
proficient in these topics there are
some links in the description box to
videos that go into much more detail for
example if you show your Muslim friend
that the Quran commands Christians to
judge by the gospel he or she might
think that some other verse in the Quran
claims that the gospel has been
corrupted
but I've got a video that goes through
every single Quran verse that mentions
the gospel and Allah always always
always affirms the inspiration
preservation and authority of the Gospel
that we have
so you can check out other videos for
further study if you want to look up
passages in the Quran you should have no
trouble finding a Quran you can read
online for those of you who prefer
reading an actual physical copy I
recommend ordering a copy of the
critical Quran
the link is in the description box
[Music]